well good excellent welcome everybody to
the final session I'm gonna kick off now
because we have got a ton of information
to cover today okay just an absolute ton
so the sort of speed of today's talk is
we're gonna start off basic and then
we're going to ramp up okay so get ready
for a wave of information to come over
you because this is going to be pretty
intense and especially for the final
session of the conference but don't fret
because of course these videos are all
recorded and this presentation is
designed to be just kind of viewed later
on as well okay so don't feel like you
need to you know get writers cramp but I
try to keep up so identity server for
angular 2 and asp.net core these are the
three things I'm going to be covering
today the main part of the the main
focus of the talk is identity server 4
okay angular I'm going to show you how
I've set up my angular 2 application or
whatever version of angular they're up
to these days and the reason I include
asp net core is because all of what I'm
doing today runs on asp net core ok
including angular so keep that in mind
but yes the focus is definitely on
identity server 4 and I'm super excited
and I'm a little bit scared a little bit
nervous and that is because the code
we're looking at today is my real-world
application ok this is running in
production
there's commented code around the place
there's probably rubbish bits and pieces
here and there and I'm just literally
loading up my solution and so if you see
a key you didn't see a key if you see a
password you didn't I have to rotate
them every time I do this talk which is
good practice for me anyway it forces me
to do it
so as a bit of context for why I'm here
today about a year ago I decided to
begin a startup in the payments industry
I used to work for a payments company it
was rubbish their systems were awful it
was mainly vb6 all of the logic was
installed procedures and I thought oh I
could do such a better job than these
guys now it turns out I learnt a lesson
a little later on
it doesn't matter how good your code is
if people are willing to pay for your
product and the other way around
basically it's your sales team that
makes a product and I only wanted you
know a little application anyone a
unicorn I'm happy with just a tiny
little business that works and it earns
a little bit of money I'm happy with the
doge of applications so I started out as
you would with you know any good startup
should as you find the MVP right you
find the simplest thing that will work
that get hand to someone and they can go
oh that's cool here's some money and so
I started off with an architecture that
looks like this now being a payments
company I rely on the banks to do all of
my transfers under the hood and if
anyone has ever worked with a bank you
might understand what's happening here
it took me nine months to get access to
the systems I needed nine months it was
ridiculously slow and so as with any
kind of developer who's got some time on
his hands
you know I ended up with an architecture
that looked like this rather than
actually you know working on finding
customers talking to you know business
people and that kind of thing I thought
oh you know what I'll just add one more
little thing I'll just investigate one
more technology because I want my
product to be you know super solid and
really really great for developers
because the whole point of my product is
to let developers access payment systems
easily okay and this is where identity
server really shines
but perhaps I shouldn't have gone so far
so I now have quite a complex system
architecture but at least I know the
intricacies of all these systems the
actors I've spent a long time gold
plating them so anyway we want to build
something like this right we want to
build an API that we can give out there
developers and we want solid systems
that are protected we using identity
server so where do we start with beer
that's right if you don't know me I am
Ben who likes beer I was working on the
beer that was at the party last night
with Aalsmeer
and so I really enjoyed that if you saw
the videos on Facebook you can see just
how excited
to go ahead and visit this Barry but if
you want to follow me on Twitter you can
follow me there it's probably the
easiest place to find blog posts or
something like that about this kind of
stuff just really quickly I was a
solution architect at SSW that was a
year ago I still do a little bit of work
for them I like payments I like beer has
untapped if you haven't seen that yet
you should install it follow me I'm Ben
Cole and I'm working on the startup
which is of course pinch pinch payments
and so this is the code we're gonna be
looking at today okay now just before we
dive into code I want to cover just a
little bit about asp.net core and why I
chose that as my platform and why you
might want to do that yourself as well I
guess the first reason is the latest
version of identity server runs on
asp.net core so if you're using that
then you're going to need to use asp net
coordinate so who's using ASP net core
here already
okay cool it's about three-quarters of
the audience for those of you who aren't
convinced yet things are fast okay
things are pretty damn quick and you
don't have to do anything to you know
reap these performance benefits
everything that they're doing now
they're focusing on performance it's
highly composable and this is kind of
comes back to identity server as well
right it's just a package that gets put
into an MVC website it's really easy to
write these extension points and write
these products to just slide into other
applications so using ASP net core makes
things a lot easier to compose it's got
all the attention right now okay you've
got Damion and David working on this
stuff and all these teams are working on
this stuff all the time now this is a
double-edged sword it changes every week
which if you're not developing every
week is a pain in the ass so it's good
because it has attention and it's
getting updates and they're making
things better and better but they're not
changing it all the time too and so that
is a little bit annoying if you're not
ready for pain and breakage and probably
my main point especially for people
newer to asp.net it's easier to do the
right thing so it kind of funnels you
towards success with the built-in
dependency injection it kind of makes
you architect your solution in a way
that sets you up for success okay it
makes it
good guides you towards good
architecture and just a quick point on
on performance here's a quick slide from
this week all of this stuff's in Asia
and you you can look at this you can see
okay are things are coming back under
two hundred milliseconds the page
it's an angular page so it takes a
little bit to load here and there it's
fairly steady requests someone had a
[ __ ] tripped over the power cord in the
middle there and they plugged it back in
hence the failed requests and you might
think okay yeah that's not bad but you
could remember that this is on
Australian service okay this is an
Australian Internet which is rubbish and
so these speeds are actually pretty
decent they say that in Australia we
have a hundred megabyte a hundred
megabits down and up the problem is the
whole country has to share
so asp.net core is a good idea okay it's
it's nice it's fun to use and it's it's
performant and the first thing you do
when you begin a project usually one of
the earlier things you do is you need to
think about security and authentication
mainly okay pretty much every system has
a user that needs to log into that
system and this is where we're going to
start talking about identity service
specifically now over the last year it's
been kind of scary there's been a lot of
data breaches being you know a lot of
security threats and even myself if you
haven't seen have I been pwned by Troy
hunt it's a fantastic tool it tells you
when you've you've had a data breach
against your email account you can see
I've been breached five times things
like LinkedIn github Ashley Madison
hopefully not and so I asked Troy I was
a bit scared I said I need some advice
what can I do to make my application
secure because I'm not a security expert
I just want to make good applications
and he gave me some great advice but I
think what he meant to say is don't roll
your own security okay there are tools
in the box that can do this for you and
there are safety in numbers
when you all rely on Microsoft and these
kinds of smart people to take care of
this kind of stuff for you and so when
we talk about security in an asp.net
core world we're talking about two
things
asp.net identity which take
care of storing these names of passwords
an identity server that takes care of
bearer authentication and giving out
tokens now a quick quick quiz here so a
quick poll here who's used asp.net
identity in dotnet core so far yep and
who's used identity server before as
well okay so about half the room I ASP
not an identity and about a third I
think I've used identity server which is
good because we're going to start off
with the basics and how to get up and
running and then I'm gonna shove you
into the things that aren't in the
documentation okay the things that you
won't be able to find it or do easily
because it's so flexible and so as I
said we'll look at asp.net identity
first and its job is just to save use
names and passwords in the database
essentially it log you into an NBC
website you can use cookie
authentication but the goal is basically
yes that's what asp.net identity takes
care of and we'll look into that in a
minute
the problem happens when you add in an
API okay what happens when you want to
expose your data to third parties using
an API and all of a sudden you're you
know cookie based authentication is not
going to cut it and so this is where we
rely on the second piece of technology
now identity server because what it does
is it wraps your asp.net identity
website ok the place where you log in it
wraps that up and it issues tokens to
your clients your third parties to
protect your API in this case but then
you can also add other things so just a
couple of quick points before we dive
into some code here are some scenarios
where identity server is a good idea for
you okay the first thing is that it's
compatible with any authentication
system okay so if you're coming from a
legacy application and you want to start
implementing this stuff you don't have
to wrap a speed I density you could wrap
an on-premises ad or an azure ad or a
custom implementation if you have one
especially if it's legacy which I hope
you then update to something else it
includes all of the things like Google
and Facebook logins and the external
open ID connect stuff
it's not quite micro-services but we are
lifting a responsibility and putting it
at its own place so it's kind of one
step towards segmenting your application
a little bit more which I like I
wouldn't call it micro services but it's
on its way you can give out different
claims to different clients so this is
just about permissions okay so if you
want one group of people to access a
certain part of your API and a different
group of people to have limited access
or something like that it's very easy to
do that with identity server and some
claims if you're building an API that's
designed to be given to third party
developers this product is perfect okay
it is an excellent tool for building
exactly what you need highly flexible
and powerful and on the flip side of
that if you've got lots of your own
applications okay you're an organization
with many internal apps and you just
want to you know use one ad
authentication for all of them this is
also a perfect tool for single sign-on
within an organization so the point of
today is that we are going to look at
the code that is this we're going to
spin up an asp.net identity server and
identity server sorry and we're going to
take a look at the code that protects
our API and how our angular 2
application is set up within MVC to make
use of this identity server as well so
just to give you an idea and I apologize
as well
I couldn't get duplicate to work so I
have to work from extend mode which is a
little tough
I realize the solution Explorer is going
to be a bit small and we have to restart
this is well we're going to do is I'm
going to fire up each of the
applications and I'm going to guide you
through I'm just going to give you a
quick demo of what it looks like to log
in so I have an API so project that I've
just spun up I have an authentication
project which is just an NBC site with
identity server inside of it it's been
that up as well we can also spin up our
website and this will load so one thing
you'll notice when it loads if we get
internet on this side as well one thing
you'll notice when it loads is we won't
be logged init we shouldn't be logged in
and I'm using a pretty heavy build
process so it does take a few minutes a
couple seconds to load now we probably
shouldn't be logged in maybe we will be
but what will happen is we'll load up
our main application our angular 2
website and immediately will be
redirected to the authentication website
where it'll ask us to login
as you can see lightning fast and the
point of this is we're login we'll go
across maybe we'll skip this step wait
for it to load up in the background no
no there we go okay cool I also have my
database migrations and my seeding of
the database on startup as well so
normally this would be spun up
beforehand but essentially what what has
happened is we've been flicked over to
our authentication server I'm going to
login using the asp.net identity
provider essentially and when I do so
I'm redirected back to my angular 2
application it loads up and it will
start being able to use the API so I can
come over here to something like payers
and it will load a list of payers and
there they are and we can come in here
and see something work like that cool so
we have our three pieces we have our
three pieces here API identity server in
angular 2 server on startup probably
something you won't realize has happened
the API project has gone and it's hid
the identity server is downloaded the
public key ok so every access token is
signed using a certificate and the
public key is given to the API so that
it can verify the tokens that it's
receiving from the angular 2 app so when
a normal request comes in we tried to go
to the angular 2 website
we weren't logged in so we get
redirected over to identity server token
comes back once we've successfully
logged in we send that token up to the
API with all of our requests and if we
have access and permission we will get
the data back ok this is the general
workflow of this particular bit and so
now what we can do is build these things
so let's take a look all right ok cool
so we're going to do is we to start and
we're just gonna quickly add asp net
identity to our project
okay so the thing you need to know about
this solution is that the pinch north I
know it's a little bit hard to see but
we're in one MVC project here and this
one is where we're going to add asp.net
identity and also identity server so the
first thing you want to do is add your
packages
all right is that large enough for
everyone to see at the back as well yeah
sweet okay so the first thing we're
going to do is add our asp.net identity
packages okay and that's these two guys
here identity and energy framework cork
we're gonna be using energy framework to
connect everything together so you add
those two packages to your just a file
new project MVC application and then in
startup you come down here look and
you'll have to bear with me and look at
this in stages all we're doing is we're
adding identity you've got a few options
that you can configure here I've turned
down the password requirements for
easier development time stuff and the
key bit is that we're adding the entity
framework stores and pointing it at
pinch context so pinch context is just a
regular database context that inherits
from identity DB context okay this can
be empty the only thing you need is the
constructor here I've got a bunch of
other tables in there but for now you
don't need to worry about that the
identity dbcontext spins up all of the
user tables and the role tables and all
those bits that are built in and the
only thing you do need to do is provide
a user and if we look at that user class
this is just a regular entity that
happens to inherit from identity user
that gives us the password and all those
other columns but the user is just a
basic class so we have our context and
that is pretty much all you need to do
to add identity you can come down here
to the configure section and you just
need to add use identity into your
pipeline okay and it has to be above MVC
for those of you who don't know because
this pipeline is executed in order MVC
if it has to be at the bottom okay
so the other thing you'll need from that
is the controllers and the views for
things like log in register and all that
kind of thing now if you go file new
project an MVC project and you'd pick
individual accounts for authentication
you'll get given these things we're
going to change them in a minute and
so really all you need to do is those
couple of bits from a blank project and
you and you'll be ready to go because
what we will do next is the next slide
we'll add identity server to this blank
empty MVC project so starting in the
same vein we need to add a few more
packages again we're still in the same
MVC project here we're going to need to
add identity server 4 as a package the
base package and then if you look at the
top here we've also adding identity
server forward or entity framework and
identity server for dot ASP denied
identity and this just makes it really
easy to use entity framework and
connected to our asp.net identity
provider ok it handles pretty much most
of it for us back into our startup class
and we'll just go back up to where we
were here you can see that I am adding
the database context in the typical
built in asp.net core way you might
notice that I've got my Kem migrations
assembly referenced there as well and
we'll talk about migrations in just a
second what we need to do is skip at
identity we've got MVC in there that's
all built in what we need to do is this
services don't add identity server here
and it's very similar to add identity ok
move up we've got some options that we
can change I've changed the login and
logout URL importantly we're adding a
signing certificate we're adding two
configurations store two database
contexts essentially and we're telling
it to use the user table so three really
important points here starting with the
certificate now as I mentioned before
whenever identity server generates a
token it's signing that token using a
certificate and you have the option
during development time if you'd like
it's come in here and go add developer
credential add developer sign in
credential and that just generates a
little key pair and it's tempting to use
this from the beginning just to get up
running but when I'm here to tell you is
that it's probably not a good idea
because you can't deploy it anywhere
it's not going to work on as you or
anything like that and it's pretty easy
just to make a cert and you know do it
properly so you may as well do that and
so to do that we've got this bit of code
above us and what we're doing here is
we're loading a certificate from the
registry it happens to be the store name
I and the store location current user
and the reason for this is that this is
where Asia places its certificates so
all of my stuff's in Asia and I like it
to work that way so to load certificates
I'll give you a link to this code in
fact what I will do if you just search
Ben car blog or even just creating an
entity or something like that
my latest post is how to do this okay
how to create a certificate how to
register it with Azure and here's that
exact same code we just saw before and
how to use it with Azure app services
because there is something you need to
do so the easiest thing to do there is
just Google Ben Cole blog or Ben Calder
calm there's there's a bunch of ways to
find this you could also just Google
creating a science certificate but the
end the end part of that goal is we load
the certificate and we pass it into
identity server the next thing I want to
show you or the next thing I want to
point out because again this is kind of
not really in the documentation either
is how to do AF migrations with multiple
DB contexts because that was a little
bit tricky to set up has anyone here
done if uses entity framework to start
okay it's the bulk of the room who uses
any framework migrations worthy of core
I guess you have to these days and who
has used multiple contexts with EF
migrations before perfect that was
no-one that's what I like to see so
you'll have to with this and it's not
too bad you'll notice I'm pointing all
of my databases to the same sorry all of
my connection strings to the same
database because I just prefer to have
it all in one spot especially on Azure
it's cheaper
and it brings it together easier so if
you look at my data project I've also
got a blog post on how to do this as
well so I'll leave that for the blog
post but essentially what happens is you
have a standard sorry a dotnet standard
class library okay this is what my data
project is and inside that you reference
entity framework and such and what you
need to do is add something called a
temporary dbcontext Factory okay so the
tooling isn't quite there yet to
understand how your application spins up
so it knows what the database status is
so it knows how to connect and all that
kind of stuff
so what you do is you add this
particular dbcontext Factory just
pointing to my development copy of my
database and that way when I run dotnet
EF migrations it knows where to find the
database and I've done that not only for
my applications context but also for the
two contexts that identity server
requires okay they all just there it's
all just the same code and again if you
go back it's just the second one here
energy framework core migrations in
Visual Studio 2017 and that will show
you how to set up multiple contexts but
essentially all you do is once you've
got that temporary database context
factory you just call and I'll just show
you very briefly
on your data project you don't know if
migrations add my migration you give it
the context named pinch context okay and
that is going to add the migration for
your own application and you do that
first and then second you come along and
you just put in the configuration
dbcontext or whatever the context name
is that you have in your database here
what is it called persisted grant DB
context and configuration DB context and
what that does is it spins up the
migration for the tables that identity
server uses you can kind of see I
apologize for the size you can kind of
see at the top right there that it's
made to folders for these things and
they just have one migration in them at
the moment because identity server
hasn't changed its data database
structure yet okay as a 1.0 but that's
an important tip is getting all your
migrations set up and probably what I'll
also show you just as a bit of a bonus
the starters we needed to add identity
server and to the bottom of our
authentication project startup class it
needs to go below identity because it
relies on some stuff in identity and it
needs to go above MVC because it
protects MVC and the bonus tip here is
just this migration and seeding of the
database so there's a bunch of different
ways to do this my preferred way to
migrate and see the database is to place
the migration and seeding code in the
configure in the pipeline part of the
startup class because this will one runs
sorry this will run once per startup and
the caveat is that if you've got a
synchronous code it needs to run
synchronously okay if you try to it will
function if you run it asynchronously if
you use a wait but it will actually
break things so use the get a waiter on
the end of your seeding stuff beautiful
okay cool
so that's technically what we need to do
to
identity server slipped into our
application okay the next thing we need
to do is understand our architecture and
we need to start configuring you know
our identity server to understand our
environment in our architecture so the
key things there our we'll start with
resources okay for those of you who
haven't used the identity server there
are two types of resources that it
protects information and an API resource
okay so information or identity
resources is just information about a
user so in this case I've got things
like their user name basic profile
information an email address importantly
I've got a custom identity resource in
my application everyone who signs up to
the website is a everyone who signs up
to the website is a merchant ok and this
is the information about that merchant
that I want to protect or I want to give
out for example and you can see in the
user claims section here this is the
stuff I want to give out just some IDs
and some names so they don't have to
keep looking it up out at the database
every time it's just embedded in the
token so that's the identity resources
the API resources our API one this is in
our earlier diagram this is the API want
to protect the other project it's just
the configuration of it so I've called
it API one it's got a secret forget the
secret it's got some user claims these
are just things that I want embedded in
the access token when you ask for this
API and it's got some scopes now scopes
is more of an OAuth idea and the thing
you need to know here is that you've got
a create a scope with the same name as
your API don't worry that's in the
documentation so that's okay and
something special I have also added is a
secondary scope
so this holds or this gives you access
to a slither of my API that I only want
certain people to have so all
third-party developers can have
everything else but only my angular 2
portal has access to the API keys
because I don't want my third-party
developers just taking the keys from the
customers they have access to and so
I've also got a second API but we we
won't look at that that's okay
so now that we have our resources okay
we've mapped out logically what we want
to protect the next thing we need to do
is add the configuration for our clients
okay so these are things that want to
connect to our API so in my case the the
main client is my angular 2 application
and we'll take a look at its
configuration here ok so when you've got
a client my main one is the angular 2
application so any client though that
tries to connect to your API and it
tries to go through identity server will
go through this client store and this is
kind of this is the stuff that's not
quite in the documentation or not widely
available anyway and this is my
preferred way of implementing the client
store ok rather than using the database
for everything I kind of have a hybrid
bit here so a client will connect using
their client ID in my case it's pinch
web for the angular 2 portal it's pinch
web anyway and if we go and we take a
look at the configuration of that client
ok let's have a look here you can see
I've got a bunch of different properties
the important ones here that I set the
URI so I know information has to come
from that website require consent is
false
ok I don't need to ask users whether or
not my portal can access my data okay
it's got implied consent
it's got allow offline access which lets
you ask for a refresh token and then
refresh your access tokens over and over
and over it has a secret to prove who I
am
this is the string you would need to
pass in to say yep you definitely are my
application and importantly here we have
allowed scopes now allowed scopes you
can see here I'm asking for the identity
information I was protecting earlier and
I'm also asking for API one merchant
which is some identity information and
Merchants API keys okay so so I'm not
asking for it I'm allowing that client
access to that scope okay so this is how
you protect certain parts of your API is
through this allowed scopes this client
connects that can access that one and
we'll contrast that now to what a third
party developer client looks like now
just as a quick just as a quick sort of
context thing whenever you sign up for
an account I generate a merchant ID in a
few keys right and this is just strings
I've made up and I'm just saving in my
merchants table okay there's nothing
special about any of this
but that merchant ID and that secret key
are what are provided to identity server
to identify this client so I find a
third-party developer building a system
and I want to use my API this is the
configuration that they will get so
we'll come back up to our client store
the client ID that comes in will be that
merchant merchant ID that I've saved in
my database so it's not going to be any
of the ones I know like I hard-code know
about it's something from the database
so I look up the merchants table and I
go okay are there any merchants with a
merchants idea of this one and if there
are I get the configuration like so
given the merchants from the database by
the way and what I can do is set up a
client I can give it its name from the
database whether or not it's enabled so
you can trigger that at this point if
you'd like to important things here the
client secrets is just the secret key
from the database again so that's how
they prove who they are using that
secret key you can see here in the
allowed scopes they're allowed
everything except
the merchant information and the API
keys scope as well so if they try to
request it they'll be denied and they
don't have access to that area okay and
I'm also embedding a few claims in here
as well and this is just a convenience
thing I'll talk about quickly I've got
some data I don't wanna look up every
time and I want to embed it in the token
you're gonna be careful not to do this
too much otherwise it'll you know be too
large of a token but this is just stuff
like their merchant ID a couple of
internal IDs and whether or not they
have permission to use the live system
it's just information that the client
might like to know about the user using
it cool so what we'll do now is we will
jump over to looking at how to protect
our API I think first we'll do that okay
so by this time what have we done we've
set up identity server it's just a
regular MVC website we put our identity
server in there we've configured it into
the pipeline we've added the the
resources that we wanted to protect and
we've gone ahead and set up our client
configuration so that we can get
third-party developers in there as well
so what we need to look at now is how to
protect the API itself and this is
relatively straightforward to be honest
so we can go in and add the package for
access token validation identity server
for might be a bit low access token
validation and this is what we're going
to put into our pipeline to read the
tokens that we get given so if we look
at startup in our API and we'll come
down to will go past the MVC bits and
we'll come down to our pipeline so you
can see here again I use the API to
migrate my data so this is the project
I've chosen to kick off the migrations
I've got cause in there so everyone can
use it even JavaScript libraries and the
thing we need to look at is identity
server authentic a
so in the authority that's just pointing
to our identity server URL so it knows
where to go
we've got require HTTPS yep enable
caching I don't have a casing provider
so I haven't done that and importantly
I'm identifying myself as API 1 and
here's my secret and once you've done
that if we look it just like a
controller let's just pick this one for
example
what you need is authorize ok and all
the internal mechanisms kick in at this
point and they'll make sure that
everything is correct ok so if you're in
an API setting and you're using a token
and you don't have permission to use
this particular class it'll kick back a
403 if you don't have a token at all or
kick back a 401 and essentially the cool
thing about this as well is here's that
API keys method right it's just in the
same class I'm the only thing I've added
differently here is the policy merchants
API keys and this is what protects this
particular method if we look back at our
start up for the API just back up here
in the authorization section we have a
thing called add author ization
and we add a policy merchant API keys
all you have to have is a claim of scope
merchant API keys which you'll only be
given if you have permission so
therefore only my client the angular 2
application can access that endpoint and
regular third-party developers can't
beautiful okay now we can dig into some
of the angular 2 stuff and how that's
set up this is a little bit more complex
and a little bit more controversial to
be honest as well so as I mentioned
before all of my applications are
running in dotnet core and including my
angular 2 application so if we take a
look at the startup class again I just
went file new project NB C and added my
angular 2 application to this project if
we come down to the pipeline of this guy
you'll see what we need to do to protect
our angular 2 app okay and I'll also
show you how the angular stuff it's
hooked up as well so the first thing we
need to do is we're using a slightly
different authentication mechanism this
time we're not using the identity server
authorization one that we had on our API
instead we're using oh I DC connect to
identify ourselves from our angular 2
application you have to put that line in
but don't worry about it that's in the
dock Oh
things to look at here and things that
are interesting I've got a rebound on
the pipeline here who's who's using
angular 2 actually I wonder how much I
need to explain yep okay cool
that's about the quarter of the room the
thing with angular 2 is when you it's a
single page application okay so the only
endpoint I have in this MVC web site is
home index all right all traffic goes to
there and that home index boots up my
angular 2 application now what happens
when I go into it I'll show you this
actually it'll be easier to visualize
what happens when you actually go in and
navigate around we're just you know it's
just all one page application we're
loaded we're not doing any post backs
but our URL and again it's bit hard to
see is changing as we go around ok so
what happens when I just go and request
that URL you'll see that we are put back
in the right place ok now the way that
works is with this rebound stuff because
the request comes in and it's two payers
slash some identifiers ok at this piece
of middleware here on the way in for the
request it skips it says ok I don't need
to do anything on the way in so that's
that oh wait next next what it does is
it goes all the way down the pipeline
all the way through our file servers and
through down to MVC and then back up ok
and if if it hasn't been found by the
file service or there's no static files
that conserve and in our case players
slash ideas not a file it's just a URL
so then it makes its way down to NBC and
every see goes oh I don't have a I don't
have a payers controller that doesn't
exist for or for I can't find that so it
comes all the way back up the pipeline
er this thing here goes okay if we get a
404 from both the file servers and the
NBC side and the path doesn't have an
extension so it's probably not a missing
file then what I want you to do is
change the request path back to root set
the status code to 200 and push it back
down the pipeline again so we've got a
second oh wait next there and that
pushes it back down file servers go not
root I don't have a file called just
slash every seat goes our home index
that's linked to root hears home index
and so home index is rendered which
boots up my Affleck Angela to
application and then the URL though in
the browser stays the same because it
doesn't know that all this happened it
just went I want this and it said here
it is and so angular 2 picks up that URL
and says ah I have a route for this
payors slash something I'm going to load
that page up and that's why we are given
the right response essentially and just
to show you the rest of the pipeline
here you can see I'm using the use file
server so that just creates WW route and
serves every file in there I've got a
second use file server for my node
modules thanks so there are a few node
modules that I need to expose as well
and because they're in the path slash
node modules but physically on the
project the one folder up so you need to
add a second one of these to expose it
properly so that covers all the static
files and most of the angular 2
application we use cookie auth because
you have to the OID C stuff all the
tokens that we receive from identity
server in that are stored in and the
cookie in this particular application so
we do need to see we do need to add
cookie authentication and you'll see
here right below it we reference that
cookie so we're telling it where to
store the tokens when we receive them
we're using OID C and the important
things here are again you'll see this
everywhere Authority is our identity
server so we pass up that URL we say
which client we are and we prove it
using our secret in our case we're using
code and token so we're using a hybrid
flow I don't have time to get into that
one
but essentially we're just requesting
tokens we're saving those tokens into
the cookie and that's really it
basically just pointed at that kind of
stuff and just below here so all this
was doing was setting up a variable and
just below it here's where we request
what we want okay so we're in our
angular 2 portal right now we're saying
please give me these scopes and you'll
see much an API keys there and offline
access as well which is important so we
can get our Refresh token and we will be
allowed because we've proven that we are
pinch web that special client and we've
given it our key so that we definitely
know who we are all right so I will also
just show you briefly the home
controller the way we protect our MVC
application is exactly the same
authorize just at the top that's it and
that's going to handle the requests
coming in going oh you're not
authenticated kicking you over to the
identity server to log in logging you in
kicking you back taking the token from
the response and then passing it down to
your application which is the next place
I want to show you so all the steps I've
just shown you here are just how to
secure an MVC website okay there's
nothing special to angular yet you could
do that just for regular MVC sites and
you'll be done actually by now which is
great but when you want to embed angular
2 into an MVC website you've got to do
one more or a few more things and what
we'll do is go through that it's the
best way is to start with home index so
home index is the only endpoint
basically and you can see a couple
others but they're not used inside home
index is the familiar what you'd
normally put into an index.html okay
it's the root of our application nothing
really special there I won't dive too
deep into how angular works but what we
will look at is the layout file
for home index so the important part is
and I'll just give you a brief look at
the whole file so you've got some
context there all we're really doing is
loading a bunch of CSS learning if you
know modules bits that I needed
rendering the body there and then
loading all of the scripts that I need
as well as bootstrapping the application
now this is this is the bootstrapping
here I guess one of the upsides and
maybe downsides as well is I'm using
system j/s to boot my angular 2
application okay and it's a bit of last
year's technology these days everyone's
using webpack and the angular CLI to
build their applications but I'm not
really a fan of how you then are taken
out of Visual Studio and you need to use
the node web server and let web pack do
its magic I like a little bit more
explicit control over these things and
so I'm sticking to a system j/s because
I can control everything through gulp
including bundling and minification and
all that kind of stuff you explicitly
write it and whether that's a bonus view
or a detriment that's up to you but one
thing I can do and I'm quite happy about
it I'm just ctrl f5 in my MVC project
and it all just works and given the
power of a back-end if I need to do
something like for Facebook sharing you
need to render straight HTML you can't
give out JavaScript it won't accept it
and so I can catch things like that and
I've got a powerful back-end that can
then deliver something else other than
Yap if I need to it's a bit of an aside
basically what we're doing here is
booting the angular 2 application so a
development time I'm using a non bundled
version of the app and at production
time I'm using a bundled version of the
app so it's much smaller and much
quicker but for debugging it's not very
nice to have a bundled application the
key kind of trick here I guess is this
line I'm using a view component to
render my settings down to my angular 2
application okay so if we take a quick
look at that
you'll see some of the magic coming out
so this food component every time the
page runs which typically is just once
at the beginning for a single page app
what I'm doing is I'm using the
authentication context pulling out the
access toast my current access token the
current ID token which contains the
identity resources I'm also pulling out
the Refresh token so my MVC app can go
and fetch as many access tokens as I
want and this is probably another big
benefit if you're more into security is
that my refresh tokens are never exposed
the client
okay the MVC backend is the only thing
that sees a refresh token so you could
make your access token expiry really
small if you wanted to kind of mitigate
people stealing keys or sniffing keys or
something like that it will only ever
last as long as you set your access
token expiry to and then it's pretty
simple I'm just building a model and I'm
putting some data in it so I'm I've got
some base URLs that I want to give to
the client so it knows where to where
the API is and where the authentication
server is I keep the tokens just in the
backend and then I add a bunch of other
information that I don't want a call
from the database every you know every
time instead I'm just using the current
the context version of these and if we
take a look at the view I'm just hard
coding a bit of a settings file and just
rendering that information in so that's
just a global variable basically in
JavaScript and because I did it just
before the that gets rendered here so a
global variable gets rendered here just
before my angular 2 app loads so that in
my angular 2 application if we go to I
just have a service stock standard
service here and go to service that
reads the magic variable so load
settings here's is called once yeah it
Maps the magic global variable stuff to
a typed variable that I can then expose
through the rest of my application which
is quite powerful and I've got I've got
10 minutes to show you something pretty
cool as well now just before I show you
the cool thing
probably while it's loading does anyone
have any questions about things I know
that's a lot of information to absorb
does anyone have any questions about
anything they didn't quite catch or
anything like that
no cool blown away oh we got one there
yep they only have access to their own
data so the question was if a user gains
access to their access token they could
use that to try and get other people's
data from the system good question good
question so the way that's handled in my
application okay cool so the way I'm
handling this and I guess the best place
to start is to show you know or thin
occasion
when I configured my identity server up
here okay
you might have noticed these three lines
down here and this is a couple of
service implementations I've ever ridden
from the default ones and the clients
tour is one of them so when I was
showing you all that client information
stuff that's a special one the other one
is a profile service and the job of a
profile service is to take the currently
logged in user
because remember identity server knows
who's logged in it's to take that user
and it's to create claims from that data
and here I've got an a spinet identity
profile service I had to write one
because they did there wasn't one before
I wrote this but there's a built-in one
now so by default you'll get things like
that their user ID is a claim and the
user name and email all these built in
asp net ones right there they all get
given to you for free so they'll be in
the token if you ask for them and more
importantly I kind of override that as
well and I hit the database to pull out
any claims I need as well so I guess if
you come down here not this one
pinch profile service so I also when a
user is authenticated at the time that
they log in these claims are also
embedded in the token so you can see how
I've got test submission ID in life son
version ID
[Music]
okay in my API as a convention no not
that one
okay this is a base controller all my
controls inherit from this one and what
I do is I look in the the canary HTTP
context and I'm looking for a merchant
context if I haven't already put one in
but essentially what's happening here is
when you ask for the submerged an idea
of the current user it's going to go
ahead and look for yeah it's going to go
ahead and pull this out of the current
context and it's going to pick either
the live submitted ID or the test
submerge charity from the claims so
they're since they're set at
authentication time basically all of my
code has a woops all of my services code
just has a where sub merchant ID equals
this and yeah that forces it basically
yeah that makes sense it's cool any
other questions before I just move on
yes correct
great question okay the question was the
Refresh token is not given to the client
therefore how am i refreshing my tokens
excellent point
there's actually again in the web
project this time to the angular 2 MVC
application there is a little end point
in my account controller here called
refresh tokens and that does what you
might think so
we basically take the current tokens out
of the authentication context that line
51 is the identity server code itself
okay so this is code they've written
where all you need to do is pass in the
Refresh token given some settings that's
hard to read with that oops so we create
a token client this token client is an
identity server class we give it some
settings such as the identity server the
client ID and the client secret and then
we call request refresh token we'll get
back a token and you can see here
basically I take the old token and the
new one and the Refresh token and I jam
it all into a new contact what is it
yes this is it here it claims principal
sorry basically this guy updates MVC so
it knows 1/2 this is the current
authentication context and then I just
return JSON with the new access token
and that's it so that goes back down to
the angular application and probably one
last thing to look at is the
authenticated HTTP service I've got here
this is an angular 2 service and what
this does is it wraps every HTTP call in
a retry given that and it knows how to
basically refresh the token so I'll come
down here and pretty much where's the
best one to look at
I guess for example get so you can call
get with any URL and then it turns that
request into like a lambda function
basically and it executes sit and it
will refresh the tokens if it didn't
work so stepping through that I add an
authentication Barrow header to each
request that's how the API knows who I
am that's how you pass the token to it
and that refresh method here a little
bit tricky is some observable observable
fun but basically we take the request we
wanted to do we execute it we catch the
error if it happens to give us a 401
then what we do is we call refresh
tokens so it makes a separate call off
to that MVC endpoint gets the new token
back and then adds it to the original
request and recur and fires it off a
second time basically which works pretty
much all the time
the reason I say pretty much all the
time is because when you load my
application for example if you happen to
land here there's several calls that go
off to load the data for this page and
if your token is expired it does it all
at once so it'll hit refresh tokens
three times all at once and yeah I'll
get the 401 three of three of them all
at once I'll refresh the tokens all at
once and that can cause identity server
to get into a bit of a fuss if you don't
set the refresh token this is going to
be a bit of a jump around up yeah my
sorry client store a pinch web so this
is the client configuration and you'll
see refresh token to do consider better
approach refresh token is set to reuse
which means when you use the refresh
token to get a new access token it
doesn't also give you a new refresh
token because when I call it three times
at once all of a sudden I'm in this big
mess whereas if I get the same refresh
token
each time it makes three successful
calls and just changes access tokens
really quickly but they all work and the
great thing is you can set this up per
client so maybe I want my internal have
to work that way but if I want
third-party developers to have a better
way of doing it I could set that to a
different configuration cool I'll take
questions at the end as well no it's
been a long day the last thing I want to
show you it's just something a little
bit fun is the SDK okay I wrote an SDK
basically to make things easier for
developers to use my system right now
what was fun about this and what's cool
about identity server is this something
there's the concept of connect built in
as well so up until now third-party
developers have built their own system
they have their own keys and they access
their own data but if you've ever used
something like stripe or PayPal or some
a very large API where you want to build
a system that uses other people's
accounts right and you want to connect
to their account and get keys for their
account rather than your own and this is
actually built in this is what my system
does as well so if you look at the you
know the keys page you'll see this
concept of an application ID on the
right hand side and what this lets you
do is like if you've ever seen something
like Twitter if you made a Twitter or
Facebook application you create a bit of
information and then when a third-party
application wants to use your Twitter
account it'll say hey so in so
application wants to use your Twitter do
you can do give consent and it'll say
let me tweet let me read tweets or give
me my email so that consent sort of
workflow is actually built into identity
server as well and to demonstrate this
let's just connect a pinch so it was a
very very prototype based screen here
this is given to you I've kind of half
styled it a little but this is built for
you and you can see here you can
configure all this stuff as well so I'm
asking for their identifier I can choose
whether or not to give them merchants
though all right whether I want to
concede to that I want API one access
and I want offline access and I can
remember that decision as well and if I
go yes allow all of a sudden what's
happened here is my third-party
application this is a technically what
some developer could go build now has
access to the my claims okay it's logged
in as me yeah it's pretty the best way
to describe it basically so the user has
logged in before that consent screen I
was already logged in but I could have
logged in as any other user and what
would happen is I would get the details
of that user in my third-party
application here and it's all the same
there's no difference to using the API
you still send enough access token
you've still got a refresh token and
you've just got some claims that you can
read and that's something I think is
really cool and its built-in but wary of
time basically what we've looked at
today is some basic how to set up
identity server stuff we'll take a look
at a ten ocation and we've kind of
really ramped up to a scenario that's
very specific to me but you've got to
see a couple of the cool things you can
do and some of the challenges you will
face when you go to do this yourself the
best place to see information about
identity server in my blog post and
stuff like that is just a Google Ben
Cole's blog you'll find information
there and thank you very much for coming
to in DC it's been a pleasure
if you have questions feel free to come
up and have a chat